[Music]
that's insane
what it is is a milkshake and cereal on
the inside hot chocolate on the outside
it's hot and it's cold it's cereal it's
exciting it shouldn't work and it does
[Music]
if you like sneakers and cereal then
kith soho is your place and now at
christmas they are doing this fantastic
matchup between dominique and cell and
this outrageously cool store
keith is always a brand that i i admire
because of what it represents and the
way they do business the way they change
as well i think there's something that
we have in common with the way we run
our business i do it with food they do
it with fashion how do you decide on the
collaborations you're going to do
because i think you get approached
hundreds and millions of times for me
it's just like it doesn't have to be
like necessarily food that we could
avoid with but the fashion burn that
has this platform and this like reach to
people i mean it's basically not what we
do yeah no i think you guys have very
good energy and like creativity and you
attract people who are like enthusiastic
and passionate absolutely like i think
we had a lot of fun like testing all
these recipes like the team at uh akif
like uh worked very very well at
actually testing and with us and uh
thinking of the ideas together so we did
a lot of as i always do like combination
of like textures and flavors and and
pairing but what works the best it's a
it's unique with way of like uh i said
i'll say eating and drinking at the same
time and it's cool for the for the
winter because you get something warm in
your hands but you still get something
cold
so teaming up with kip do you think that
is a good business model for you going
forward like do you get to bring in a
new audience when you're working with
brand like kith i think it's always like
fun to uh partner and team up with like
some
other brands that are not necessarily
related to food our range of clientele
is very very large i think that you know
the team at keith also have a specific
type of clientele and somehow like meets
at some point and still people are
excited about clothing and food at some
time yeah no i think there's definitely
an overlap but it's cool to think about
people who are passionate about sneakers
also like they recognize a dominique and
sell bag and i think in some ways if you
have the aspect of a fashion label
that's true and it's something that we
invested into you know bakery doesn't
always necessarily
need so have what looks good in terms of
like boxes and bags but i think it's
part of our brand that is a sign of
quality as well your pastries are
exquisite and fantastic like your your
playground is magnificent but this is
like coming from a different planet to
me so the fact that you could create
something that's crazy nostalgic for
people in america but not for you and
then come up with something that's
thinking totally outside the box how
long did it take you to come up with the
milkshake chocolate i've been doing this
for many many years now so i know what
what works and what doesn't before we
even try it
so when you try of course you push the
boundaries of like
and how far you can push to see like
how unique you can create a product
nostalgia is something i've been
fascinated by
growing up in france
and it's a lot a lot different so i
first came here you know like learning
about cookie people like eating cookies
and drinking meals led me to create the
milk and cookie shop so there's a lot of
the the creations that i work with are
nostalgia is so so important for me
try and get this before the holidays are
over merry kissness